all right hope you all had a great
weekend now here's a story that that
seems too hilarious to be true but but
it is true Elizabeth Warren has released
actually released DNA test results to
prove that she is Native American and
here's the report from The Daily Beast
it says senator Elizabeth Warren has
taken the extraordinary step of
releasing DNA test results that provide
strong evidence quote unquote that she
has Native American ancestry the
possible Democratic presidential
contender from 2020 has been repeatedly
mocked by Donald Trump and other
Republicans of her ancestral claims one
of trumps sick jokes is to call Warren
Pocahontas actually think that's maybe
one of his best joke I think it's his by
far his best best nickname anyway so
let's get to the meat of this the
analysis of Warren's DNA was reportedly
done by Carlos Bustamante
a Stanford University professor and
shows that she had a Native American in
her family wait wait for this okay wait
for this get ready
she had a Native American in her family
tree dating back six to ten generations
ago not six to ten years ago six to ten
Jen not even six to ten decades ago six
to ten generations ago that's the and
she's actually released this as I mean
has this woman lost her mind that that's
a serious question
has she I mean is she is she I know
she's getting up there an age I'm just
wondering if there's some kind of
senility setting in or something because
all she's done here is confirm that her
Native American claims were erroneous
this is no this is what her this is what
her opponents should be releasing no we
have information that a that native the
Elizabeth Warren's Native American
ancestral claims you know you know date
back ten generations that's what that's
what her her opponents should be saying
there's not not her she's just having
one Native American in your family tree
sometime in the timeframe of 180 to
three hundred years ago okay that's what
ten generations I think a generation is
like thirty years I think
what so if we're talking you know up to
ten generate that's three honey
we could be talking about 300 years ago
she had one Native American and her
family 300 years ago and she thinks that
that confirms her Native American
heritage it does not Elizabeth Warren
you are I'm afraid to say you are is
white bread as ever unfortunately even
more actually than a lot of people I'm
white bread but but I mean like I bet I
could go back if I if I were to date to
go look at my family tree probably I
wouldn't have to go back even six ten
generations to find a minority which is
and that's that's the thing here what
you see here is how identity politics
defeats itself because if the left
accepts this which which it appears they
are which is pretty funny in and of
itself but if you if you go on Twitter
and and you you read the thread under
where Elizabeth Warren and now it makes
this announcement about her Native
American ancestry and you read what her
followers her supporters are saying
they're all celebrating it they're
saying yeah you you you really showed
them Liz so they're accepting but the
problem is if you accept this then that
means that pretty much everyone in
America is a minority I mean almost
everybody is a minority by that
definition which is the end of identity
politics because the whole point of
identity politics is to set up this
dynamic where you've got the persecuted
minorities and then the evil white
people and that's the dynamic of
identity politics but if you can escape
the evil white people camp simply by
showing that somewhere in the distant
past in your in your bloodline
there was a minority and ethnic might if
that's enough to get you out of the then
there's not gonna be anyone left there
are gonna be no evil white people left
because now we're all minorities
apparently it's just
it's pretty incredible but I'm sure
we'll continue to follow this breaking
news story as it develops in the
meantime two other things I wanted to
talk about first of all over the weekend
the media launched what I think is is
one of the most dishonest attacks of
President Trump that we've yet seen
which I know is saying quite a lot but
Trump was at a rally in Ohio and he
began and at this rally he he went off
on this thing about about ulysses s
grant because grant is a native of Ohio
so he was complimenting General Grant
which is a perfectly fine thing to do he
said that the general was quote
incredible and he pointed out how grant
beat Robert Ely which Trump said is is
especially impressive because Lee
himself
was a great general he was saying I
forget the exact quote but Trump said
that you know Lee was beating everybody
Lincoln was scared of him couldn't
figure out and then Grant comes in and
kicks his butt you know so this is all
in the context of trying to trying to
pump up ulysses s grant but the media
had all it need needed right there as
soon as I think the media they were they
they started licking their chops as soon
as they as soon as they heard Trump
start talking about civil war generals
they were ready they were ready to copy
and paste and do what they had to do
because that was going to give them all
the material that they needed all they
needed well it didn't matter the context
all they needed was for Trump to say
something vaguely positive about a
confederate about about a about a you
know prominent Confederate figure that's
all they needed and so they took that
they they isolated the part where Trump
called robert e lee great and they took
that and they accused him of praising
robert e lee without without mentioning
that it was within the context of
praising grant and so if you went online
on saturday you would this is what you
would have seen all over the place and
if you were watching CNN this is what
you would
Oh Trump Trump was a at a rally and he
just started praising robert e lee in
fact NBC blatantly lied about what he
said they went beyond they they took him
out of context they did that also but
they went beyond simply taking him out
of context and they they just lied about
it they said that they sent out a tweet
reporting that Trump called Lee
incredible when in fact Trump called
grant incredible he never used that word
for General Lee NBC did issue a
correction we should say but they issued
it two days later in the meantime which
there's no reason why it should have
taken two days all you had to do was
actually watch the clip in question and
you would have seen what he actually
said so are we to believe that NBC took
NBC two days to actually watch the clip
that they reported on and in the
meantime in in between those those two
days they along with the rest of the
leftist media allowed this false
narrative to seep in and fester and then
they came back when and corrected it
when everyone had already moved on and
the narrative had metastasized in the
subconscious of many people and then at
that point they issued their little
correction this is the game that they
always play now this tactic by the media
was dishonest and absurd obviously and
the worst part is that they completely
divorced Trump's content comments about
Lee from the overall context they lied
about it but even aside from that
context what we also have here on
display yet again is this this this idea
that I mean I mean even if let's say
that Trump was in Virginia doing a rally
and and so he complimented robert e lee
not even within the context of
complementing General Grant well so what
who why would it even matter if he had
done that
I mean this idea is so silly that you
this idea that you must not ever say
anything positive about historical
figures who we have decided our villains
it is a silly childish dim-witted way of
looking at history and it makes any
serious study of history any insightful
or useful analysis of history impossible
if that's the way you're looking at it
you know I got into this argument on
Twitter on Saturday it was a travel day
for me I was on planes all day so I
didn't have anything better to do but
argue about the civil war on Twitter so
that's what I was doing and when this
controversy was going on I pointed out
that well first of all troubles taking
out of context but but secondly I said
Lee was a great general so so who cares
it's true what he said Lee was a great
general and a lot of people responded to
that by saying well how could how could
you say how dare you say that Lee
supported slavery he fought for slavery
he was pro-slavery fought for slavery
how could you call him a great general
now this shows not only historical
ignorant but an attitude about history
that makes it as I said impossible to
actually analyze historical events and
have a conversation about history first
of all the question of robert e lee's
feelings about slavery and his
relationship to slavery has nothing to
do with the question about whether or
not he was a great general those are two
completely different questions they are
not related to the first question it's
simply untrue and this is where the
historical ignorance comes in it is
untrue to say it is it is not true to
say that that Lee was some big proponent
of slavery and that he went to war to
protect slavery that's not true Lee did
not own slaves personally his feelings
about slavery were not enlightened by by
modern standards but by the standards of
the time they were relatively moderate
his stance on slavery was relatively
moderate even liberal by the standards
of the time
Lee also would certainly have qualified
as a he would if you were to take robert
e lee and put him into modern-day
society and and put all of his views and
everything again divorced from context
in modern-day society he would
definitely qualify as a as a terrible
racist but but so would Abraham Lincoln
Abraham Lincoln explicitly opposed
equality of the races and he said so
that he said that he does not in in any
way support the social political or
political equality of the black and
white races ulysses s grant also would
qualify as erases his wife owned slaves
grant himself for a time owned a slave
but the bigger point here is that so you
see they're making this point all the
time that you you have to analyze the
views and opinions of historical figures
within the context of the time and what
you certainly can't do is select
individual historical figures and hold
them to a modern standard but not anyone
else from that time period you know we
can't do that you can't take Abraham
Lincoln and say well he was a great
president great man yeah he was an
avowed racist but but yet you know we
got to see that within the context of
the time we can't do that with Lincoln
if we're not going to do it with robert
e lee so we have to decide are we going
to see historical figures within the
context of their time or not and if not
then we have to treat everybody in
history in the same way which means that
everybody in history we have to see that
we have to write them all off as just a
bunch of racists and bigots and
everything because ever because if you
go back 200 years or 150 years and then
go back to any point in history after
you know before that everybody was
bigoted talk to one you know into one
degree or another so clearly
we have to see things within the context
of the time but the bigger point here is
that Lee's opinions on racial issues had
nothing to do with his decision to fight
for the Confederacy Lee was not even in
favor of secession he opposed to session
now whatever reason the southern
politicians had for seceding and slavery
was a significant part of their reasons
for sure but for Lee and for most
Confederate officers and and and just
soldiers the problem was different and
for Lee you know he knew that if he
fought for the Union he would be
marching against his own home his own
community his own family his own sons
you know he would be fighting against
them he would be taking up arms against
his family and his home and his country
and when I say country we have to
understand again for the third time
understanding things within the
historical context if we do that then we
then we realize that back in those days
especially in the south when when you
talked about your country you were
talking about your state that's what you
considered your country to be most
people especially in the south they
didn't feel this allegiance in this I
did they didn't really identify
themselves with the country as a whole
they identified themselves with their
communities and their States and that's
that's the way the country was
originally set up that we are a union of
different states but each but you know
you cared first and foremost about your
community and your state because that's
your home that's where you live that's
where your family is
and especially back then without modern
technology without the internet and
phone and all that kind of stuff you
really you could how could you identify
with the entire Chi didn't really mean
anything to you the entire country you
know you had no you had really no
concept of the whole country
you had no I should say you had no real
direct connection with it or to it but
you did to to your land and your home
and your family and so that's just the
way people saw it back then
so that was the that was the the
decision he had to make he could march
against his kids country his family his
home or he could fight for the
Confederacy and defend his family and
his home and his country against those
who were invading it and he chose the
latter and that was by far and away his
primary personal motivation it was not
because he wanted to go and defend
slavery
it just it was that's just not the case
in terms of his generalship there's no
doubt that he was a great general he was
always out manned outgunned lacking in
basic resources like food and clothing
and shoes he was facing an opponent with
superior numbers superior technology
superior resources and yet Lee won
battle after battle after battle against
enormous odds and that makes him a great
general no matter how you feel about him
personally I actually think that Trump
gave too much credit to General Grant
yeah grant beat Lee but but grant also
faced Lee at a point when Lee was even
more depleted and this was after the
failure at Gettysburg
so the rioting was already on the wall
at that point and Lee knew it after he
failed in Gettysburg and had to retreat
it was I mean it was pretty much over at
that point and this was also after Lee
had had lost Stonewall Jackson so grant
was facing an already out manned and
outgunned opponent at a point when that
opponent was was even more weakened and
he won which good for him but I'm not
sure that I just I don't see why that's
considered some sort of incredible
accomplishment we only see it as an
accomplishment because up to that point
Lee had just been spanking every single
Union General thrown his way and so that
was kind of where the bar was was was
set if you went up against General Lee
it was kind of expected that he would
just spank you
but he didn't with with Grant so we
consider at this huge achievement but I
still think you have to consider what
Lee was up against but wherever you fall
on the question of who is the better jet
better general it is silly to suggest
that we have some sort of morale
dooty to immediately side with grant on
that question of who was the better of
general because you just can't do
history that way history it doesn't work
like that that's like if I insisted that
the only great musicians in history have
been the ones who were had personally
great character and were you know had
had an integrity and all of that but if
I insist on studying music that way and
viewing musicians through that lens I'm
gonna have to bypass like almost all of
the great musicians of the last 200
years so you just can't do that also
when it comes to analyzing the character
of anyone including historical figures
we can't look at them as cartoons as
caricatures I think the truth is when
you study history you'll see that there
have been relatively few straightforward
villains in history okay that is there
are relatively few people who are just
plain evil with no shades of gray
nothing just straightforward evil and
that's it I think there are very few
historical figures who fit that mold
there are some obviously Hitler falls
into that category Nero Caligula Stalin
Pol Pot Attila the Hun but and there's a
reason why we remember all those names
because these were just down to their
core evil people who were you know but
that's unusual most historical figures
are complex layered multifaceted there
are shades of black shades of white they
may have fought on the wrong side of an
issue yet been personally heroic they
may have fought on the right side yet
been personally de botched all kinds of
different combinations and what makes
history so fascinating is precisely this
dynamic because it reveals the hidden
complexities of our past and of enough
past of you know historical figures of
the past that's what that's what makes
it interesting to study history
yet it seems we're just too dumb to
ignorant too childish to study history
in this way anymore which means that we
cannot study it at all so if we're gonna
look at the center at the Civil War and
we're gonna say well everyone who fought
for the south are all a bunch of
scumbags evil terrible nothing good can
be said about them if that's the kind of
attitude that we bring to a historical
analysis of something as complex and
complicated as the Civil War then it's
just we're not gonna be able to learn
anything about history we're going to be
children who know nothing about history
and that's the kind of country that
we're living in now
all right um one other thing in order to
talk about stepping aside from anything
politically political or related to
politics for a moment on Facebook over
the weekend I shared a story that has
been getting some attention after going
viral and I'll just give you the brief
synopsis of this story as the story goes
an elderly man
cancer survivor tragically disfigured
from a life-saving surgery which which
left him without a nose without with an
empty eye socket so he's you know so
he's been tragically disfigured and this
man sat down to eat at a convenience
store and was asked by the owner of the
store to cover up so that he didn't
upset her other customers and he left
the store obviously very upset himself
and he went home and he talked to his
daughter about it
his daughter then put this story out on
Facebook giving the store owners name
her business and a picture of her and
then the post went viral and the woman
the daughter immediately started a
GoFundMe account of course and began
sharing that all over Facebook as well
interestingly the GoFundMe account
doesn't actually say what the money's
being raised for I guess you would think
well maybe this the money is too is for
reconstructive surgery for the father
which will be a great cause
but the GoFundMe account doesn't say
that doesn't doesn't say what the money
is going towards doesn't even say who's
gonna get the money it's just this woman
started the GoFundMe account and it's
already raised like seventy thousand
dollars or something like that in a
couple of days meanwhile the owner of
the store is getting blasted by everyone
across the country and you could imagine
she's getting a ton of hate mail
probably a significant amount of death
threats as well I don't know if that's
the case or not we haven't really heard
much from her which is part of the point
here but that's the way these things
always go anyone who's familiar with
internet outrage you know that there's
always death threats involved so I would
say it's almost 100 percent certain that
she's gotten death threats which which
would be concerning because her not her
not only her name but her picture was
put out there as well now the owner of
the store did try to defend herself
apparently she left a comment on the
original post by the daughter saying
that she the store owner didn't mean to
upset the man who hurt his feelings
she said that he comes in every day and
eats you know at the store and according
to her it was driving customers away and
so she says that finally after however
many days of this she pulled the man
aside privately
and talked to him about it and she
insists that she handled it the best way
that she knows how now but obviously
that did nothing to quell any of the
outrage that's coming her way now here's
the thing I obviously feel very bad for
this man it's a terrible thing that he's
going through and I won't defend the
store owners behavior I think that she
did the wrong thing we're really only
getting one side of the story but based
on what we know I'd say that she did the
wrong thing I there's really no scenario
where it would be appropriate to say
that to a cancer survivor but I don't
want to spend time analyzing the
particular zuv this story what I do want
to say is this
we really need to stop turning personal
grievances into fodder for public
consumption I'm really uncomfortable
with that I'm really uncomfortable with
the way that people will now take it
personal slight or insult the day
suffered or someone that they loved
suffered and then they put it out there
for the entire world stirring up a mob
and trying to get revenge that way I
think it's even if there really was a
slight or an insult even if something
bad really did happen even if the person
being singled out really did do
something wrong the point is I just
whatever happened to handling personal
disputes privately whatever happened to
personal disputes is like nothing is
personal anymore everything is you have
a problem with someone in your community
just put it out there for everyone so
that people that are a thousand miles
away can chime in people have no idea
about the situation don't know anyone
involved don't know anything about the
context don't know anything at all about
the situation and yet they can come in
and and and and their outrage can be
heard as well I why does the whole world
need to know about why does the whole
world need to know about this situation
between a woman her father and the owned
owner of a rest stop convenience store I
think the Internet has given everyone
the ability to use public outrage as a
weapon not only as a weapon but to
monetize public outrage as well now we
all have that ability and and I'm really
uncomfortable uncomfortable with it for
a number of reasons number one it's
dangerous you know again even if you
suffered even if you really have a
legitimate grievance which I think that
certainly this man does even though he's
not the one who put this on Facebook his
daughter did he's a legitimate grievance
even if you have a legitimate grievance
even if someone really did do something
wrong which I think this owner did it
it's it
this it's a dangerous game to play when
you put someone's name out there you put
their face out there and you send the
mob after them you you have no control
over what happens next
and I'm tell you something if you send
the mob after somebody with their
picture and their name attached even if
they did something wrong again and then
something happens to that person which
you haven't which could happen but if
that were to occur it would be partly
your fault not just partly actually
would be I mean it would be pretty much
100% your fault it's just it is very
dangerous and I think that um maybe if
you've never been the target of
overwhelming Internet outrage maybe you
just don't understand what it's like
okay if you've never been in a situation
where you're getting death threats from
all over the country left and right all
you know and or people are showing up at
your business or your house and
threatening if you've never been that
situation maybe you don't understand
what it's like but it's a very
terrifying thing and when you're in that
situation you know that you're in your
life's in jeopardy it only takes one
crazy person who's really upset to show
up and do something terrible so it's a
dangerous game number two what good can
really come of it
what what's the point what does it
accomplish where is there's there's like
no sense of proportion anymore where's
the proportionality of this so this
woman did a really rude thing it's a
terrible thing so that means what we got
to destroy your life destroy your
business put her life in jeopardy like
that really that that we immediately
jump to that and this is what you see
with this example we're not given any
indication at all that the daughter
attempted to reach out to the owner
herself privately first so she jumped
right to I'm going to the public I'm
getting the amount the mob whipped up
I'm gonna have to go fund me account
ready to go she went right to that she
didn't even try anything else
so it's a dangerous game it can't really
accomplish anything positive yeah you
can make some money off of it you could
destroy the person's life in business
but I don't really consider that a
positive outcome and so there's those
two props it's also it's just not it's
not human you know it's like we've we've
lost the ability to live personal lives
and deal with things on a personal level
we've lost that ability and I say this
this is just one example you know we see
this all the time I can tell you that
every day or at least I'll say multiple
times a week I get emails from people
asking me to share something that they
wrote on Facebook about an injustice
that they supposedly suffered at the
hands of a business owner or a school
faculty member or community member or
whatever I mean I get this all the time
because because of course people like to
air their grievances publicly but that
doesn't mean that's going to go viral so
sometimes you need that added accelerant
and so people will come to me hoping
that I'll be the accelerant of course I
never do it but but it just shows that
this is this attitude that we have that
we have a problem with someone
personally what we're gonna do you know
we're not gonna try to settle it with
them we're not going to go talk to them
we're just gonna go right to the mob and
look for revenge and maybe a little bit
of cash as well on top of it and I
really don't like that I don't think
it's the right approach now there are
look there are there are circumstances
where maybe that is appropriate so if
you if you're being persecuted in some
way by some much more powerful
institution especially a government
institution then I think to get people
involved to come to your aid I think
could that could be the right approach I
don't I still don't think it should be
your first step but eventually maybe you
do that maybe maybe and this is where
the Internet can come in handy because
it levels the playing field a little bit
but a gripe that you have with the owner
of a rest stop down the street okay that
is not a
more powerful person who you're being
persecuted by that's just another normal
person it was you know and I think so
much so much of the time that's what it
ends up being it's not that people are
going up against the more powerful
figure more powerful institution it's
more just they're looking to settle a
score with some other average person
that they know and I think we need to be
very careful about that and we need to
think about potentially maybe trying to
live our lives personally and privately
a little bit and solving our problems
that way at least trying to do that
before we jump immediately to whipping
up the mob we'll leave it there have a
great day everyone talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed